here on the coronavirus here's a look at
the latest coronavirus numbers
nevada reporting 47 more deaths there
were also 1200 more positive tests
across the state
overall cases are trending downward
however it's worth pointing out
testing is also dropping the southern
nevada health district says it is trying
to improve the coronavirus vaccination
process here
local health officials are working on
trying to figure out the best way to get
everybody
vaccinated and they say it all depends
on supply
right now officials are asking you don't
schedule an appointment if it's not your
turn remember right now it's the elderly
and first responders
starting today people can register with
more detailed information
and try and speed up the process our
appointment system
certainly isn't perfect yet and we're
working on it
we're in a much better place than we
were last week
meanwhile cashman center's vaccination
site is closing tomorrow
all through the weekend they're making
improvements there appointments for next
week
will be available soon on the southern
nevada health district's website
we know you have a lot of questions
about this that we have all the
information you need
at eightnewsnow.com local smith's
grocery store pharmacies have started
giving vaccines to people 70 and older
the company hopes this is going to make
it easier for
local seniors who might struggle to get
to those mass vaccination sites
they were excited because they don't
want to end up in the hospital
especially my grandmother she had a very
bad experience and she didn't want to go
through that
again smith's says it's only allocated
about a hundred doses per week per
clinic and they're distributed by
appointment you have to make one of
those first